so I have what we call I don't even
asked a lot of stuff I have a few want
to call fun questions let's see what how
this goes Pope uh who wins in a fight
Hobbs in Shaw or Victoria from red
Victoria from red uh who wins in a fight
Hobson Shaw or Catherine the Great Oh
Catherine oh I can see those hubs in
Shaw or the Queen okay uh-huh flu shot
or d c---eight antenna Jane Tennison I'd
have to go with Jane I'm sorry hopes um
sure Hobson Shaw or Morgana
oh go smoke on uh she's got powers that
they don't have um I know you didn't
really work with I don't think you
really worked with Dwayne Johnson in the
movie yeah I'd love to
I was gonna I was gonna say I've been
asking everyone the question of who
ruined the most takes Hobbes Warshaw ha
ha ha I would I would say probably hopes
I would say probably hopes um who is
sure it's very very professional right
what about who is faster at leaving
their trailer I don't know but I have to
say that sure was very fast he was he
was very you know immediately the minute
the set is ready he's there he's the
most professional actor who wins in a
fight Hobbes in Shaw or Jason Bourne
oh I cops ensure Hobbes in Shaw or
Deadpool okay
Hobbes in Shaw or John McClane die hard
from John McLean okay uh Hobson shot or
the Terminator Hobson Shaw okay Hubbs
and Shaw or rocky with the rocky theme
music playing well that's a decent is
that's a terrible disadvantage that's
not fair right
how can they possibly win if the music
is playing I'm just wondering I'm
throwing up possible yeah
Hopson Shaw or the predator uh Hobson
Shaw
okay Hobson shot or Bruce Lee okay
Hobson Shaw or Indiana Jones Hobson show
Robin Shaw or Ripley Sigourney Weaver in
aliens me okay with the girls
Hobson Shaw or Sarah Connor Terminator 2
oh yes good one but I I'd give it to
Hobson sure I think okay I've seen the
new trailer for that Terminator and she
still seems like a badass just throwing
that out there swing it out there yeah
Hobson shot where Liam Neeson and taken
I can't I come I'm gonna have to call
that one a draw two and we have what we
want is to see them all in the same
movie together that would be great I
agree with that um I want to thank you
so much for your time and indulging my
stupid questions thank you seriously
thank you